the digital bugs and star trip troopers
are still some of my favorite cg effects
in film
[Music]
it's all about the direct connection
between the puppeteer and the
performance
almost every single shot is entirely in
camera wow that actually this is
completely blowing my mind right now
today's episode is brought to you by
keeps stick around to the end to get 50
off great hair loss prevention products
and keep the hair that you have
hey how's it going welcome back to
another episode of visual effects artist
react today is an incredibly special
episode because we're going to be
looking at practical effects with none
other than the practical master himself
adam savage that's a lot to live up to i
mean is it though i don't know i think
it'd be pretty easy for you to live up
to that one i'm adam savage uh i am a
youtuber formerly a myth buster before
that i was a special effects uh artisan
and model maker for 20 years we are
visual effects artists generally by
trade and so it's interesting to hear
your perspectives on how these effects
are created but done for real
i want to look at a little shop of
horrors oh
frank oz's film how about that you
talked you you open your trap you you
sing and you see me grab on feed me now
it's an unbelievable practical effect
there's like five six eight people
operating all these parts of that plant
to get this performance out what i love
about it though is the fact that they
had to take special consideration with
how they filmed it in order to make the
movement seem natural
right right
they're ramping the camera in one
direction right yes so what they're
doing is they're under cranking the
camera a little bit so that they can
compress those frames into a normal
frame rate speeding it up they
essentially played out the lines at a
very slow speed so that all the the
puppet work and the model work of the
that mouth because it's very articulate
but it's moving at speeds that something
of that mass wouldn't be able to
physically do right what about the split
screen where they're both in frame yeah
is that like all in the same take or is
he like being composited somehow on top
of that that's a very good question
because it turns out rick moranis is an
excellent actor and was able to act in
slow motion he's acting well look if
stinky could dance in slow motion
i'm sure
and you can kind of tell when rick
moranis is walking towards the door he's
walking slowly so he's having to balance
on each leg after every step he takes so
it kind of creates a little bit more of
a wall
yeah you know because when you normally
walk you carry your momentum through
your steps yeah of course i know frank
i've like talked to frank about making
this film and he talks about the
collaboration of all of these puppeteers
getting us to work it's mind-blowing to
me there's so much going on each of the
leaves each of the branches has specific
gestures that are timed to the script i
mean they must have storyboarded this
out like an animator beats out
every frame of an animation
i know from knowing muppeteers that one
of the axioms on jim henson's sets were
you didn't stop until it was right like
literally jim had the power at the peak
of his career you just didn't stop until
everyone was happy i'm gonna go down to
schmedricks and pick you up some nice
chopped sirloin must be blood i've been
doing a lot of like face mo cap and like
trying to get like blend shapes of
people talking digitally and stuff like
that and there's this thing called like
visemes when we talk there's a like a
set of visemes which basically define
the lip shape of every sound a mouth
makes
and having a puppet that's able to
actually like recreate those because of
the the intricate lip motions that's
what really sells when something's
talking it's like subtle movements of
the lips that you're just so accustomed
to seeing but if they're not recreated
at that level of detail it just looks
like you know a ventriloquist
you know although his head carapace his
head looks like it's hard it's very
likely to be shram uh foam rubber like
the consistency of makeup sponge some
people have a skin type i have a certain
kind of sweat that when i touch
special effects foam rubber i turn it
yellow oh oh
i i have what's called piss hands in the
industry
and so i was visiting down at weta and
they were showing me some castings they
were pulling out of foam rubber and i'm
like i can't touch it i have his hands
like oh stay away
because you really will turn it yellow
if you start to handle it so i can't
remember where this came out in relation
to teenage mutant ninja turtles which
some of the best animatronics that's
ever been put into a movie is in the
second ninja turtles movie okay and i
know that actually that henson's uh one
of their animatronic controls was a
specific mouse controller that allowed
you to put all these hand gestures
into the controller itself that would
translate out to the mouth so it's not
just someone going i'm curling the top
of the lip i'm curling the bottom of the
lip it's more like they built a gestural
controller that makes sense it's more
intuitive right right but i think you
still had on some of those puppets two
separate people using both their hands
just to get the mouth to work
there's still a way in which henson was
prioritizing performance and
prioritizing that direct connection
between the puppeteer and the
performance because that was their bread
and butter right like it's all about the
translation from here to the script
i mean this the haiti set is one of the
great effect shots in film history and
this is this is every model making
technique there is there's fiber optics
there's grain of wheat bulbs there's
transparencies with lights behind them
the flames coming off the building some
of those were grabbed from the antonioni
film zabraski point and matted onto the
buildings all of the work in blade
runner every single effect shot there's
almost no process composite shots in
blade runner almost every single shot is
entirely in camera
in order to do these in camera what
they're doing is exposing for shadows
exposing for environment exposing for
lights blinky lights building lights the
spinner moving every single one of those
elements that i've listed is a separate
motion control camera pass okay yes and
because the motion control camera is has
100 repeatability every single time
you're just blacking out everything else
okay so when the flames come off the top
of a building they're literally for that
past they're just putting a white card
over that building and projecting the
flame on it frame by frame as the moco
pass is happening and then removing it
and because they're doing that one pass
for that one exposure nothing else gets
exposed wait a minute this isn't like
five
pieces of film that it's being created
it's
okay so i get it no i get it i get one
piece of film multiple exposures for
star wars they also used motion control
systems and they would do separate
passes of everything but they would film
them on different sets of films whereas
in blade runner all of these exposures
are happening on the same piece of film
in order to get the final shot i mean
you can see how the flames are lighting
up the building you're right i didn't i
never saw it i never noticed that
wow
actually this is completely blowing my
mind this is why this movie looks better
than anything that has been produced
since full stop i have not even
qualified well that's because when
you're doing with multiple film like
there's that level of degradation that's
happening and you lose that fidelity and
you see it you see it all the time when
there's like early blue screen work
happening or anything that requires a
map basically and an in-camera passes
you are always 100 getting the first
pass on to the celluloid and because
we're dealing with film
it's purely just exposing the chemicals
of the film itself
how long is this shot this shot is let's
say it's 10 seconds long that's 240
frames they're taking that piece of film
and rewinding it past the gate all 240
frames and re-exposing every single one
25 separate times dang when you lose a
generation in compositing the key thing
you lose is the tiny aspects that
communicate scale
and that's why these in-camera passes i
think are just unbeatable but it took 16
or 20 in-camera passes each one of which
took hours so on this set they're
getting one of these shots per week so
the producers are like yes stop doing
that
yeah but look at it though no but look
at it i know
[Music]
oh my god this is this is all really
wonderful because the digital bugs and
star trip troopers
are still some of my favorite heavy
heavy duty cg effects in film i love
these bugs these books have also kind of
like laid the foundation for the whole
like alien bug aesthetic too like you
see them in video games a lot they look
just like this starship troopers was it
was literally like the disaster everyone
loves to talk about like if you worked
on starship troopers there was there
used to be this i don't want to name him
i'm going to call him boozer okay
because i don't want to name and shame
somebody from the past who could be
watching this let's call him boozer
there was a guy named boozer worked in
special effects who was a total
complainer okay like a real [ __ ]
disturber and just like why are you
working so hard man the man is boning
you don't work so hard the crew hats for
star trip troopers say on the back
boozer was right
yeah like that's the level that we're
talking about oh my god
[Laughter]
what i love about star troop troopers is
it's
phil tippett's triumph after the shaman
ignominy of of jurassic park frankly
like i i don't think he thinks of it as
a shameful episode but like the fact
that phil was going to do the dinosaurs
and then didn't do the dinosaurs was a
really significant and rough hit like
yeah absolutely how could it not be also
my a friend of mine said this years ago
he said what's great about starship
troopers is in any place where the
script is absurd the film basically
holds its own script up for ridicule i'm
doing my part too
[Music]
okay
this film is actually making fun of
itself as it's going and it was very
much so underappreciated when it came
out i think people completely missed the
the satire of it and what it meant as
like a theme and people just kind of saw
it as a superficial action flick and
it's like that's not what it was trying
to be
it's afraid
it's afraid
and now i've seen articles where like
it's just propaganda and i'm like that's
anti-propaganda
just get your storm straight
[Music]
i wish i could participate
but you know if i go to
quarterdigital.com and watch the
extended cuts there it's almost like i'm
actually there check it out you get all
that deep inside baseball talk and
extended stories from these amazing
guests have decided to join us for only
399 pennies a month you can subscribe
and watch all of our stuff without ads
plus we have a whole bunch of cool
original shows son of a dungeon lots of
good stuff quarterdigital.com check it
out
have fun guys
[Music]
will you get a load of this
space cowboys i built this shuttle for
that movie it is the most detailed model
of a shuttle that anyone's built for a
film we scratched every bloody top we
got orthographic layouts of the tiles
and scribed every tile line into that
model because clint is cheap in the best
way and he's like no no you only get to
build one model for all of our effect
shots
so for the scenes in which the shuttle
is entering the earth's atmosphere you
see the wind glowing they literally took
the wing and applied 3m scotchlite
material to the wing and shined a red
light at it to get the glow
okay when clint steps out of the airlock
in this film into the payload bay that's
my model that he's walking around in and
like behind him
fills a movie screen and it's a 12 inch
wide model wow when you're sitting in a
theater and you're looking at a 70 foot
wide screen and you know it's 12 inches
of your hard-earned labor there's like
seven months of just working on that
payload bay we did a bunch of camera
testing to figure out what gold foil to
use oh
because there's a lot of different golds
and for us for our camera test it was
rolo wrappers so we bought cases of
rolos and so there was somebody one
model maker spent spent a day unwrapping
hundreds of rolos and making a stack of
precious rolo foil so we're literally
looking like we're looking at it
underneath there it's just like a
chocolate residue
that's so funny because i've had that
thought before because it's like you see
especially like the lunar lander with
all that gold foil there and i remember
unwrapping the rolo and being like this
looks like the moon lander
so this shot we're seeing here then
that's a spacesuit that's a guy on a
screen or is that a cg guy full cg it's
one of the or it's an er yeah it's early
so it's a full cg clint looks good it
looks great it looks really good all
right that's the i was looking at the
feet and the shadows and it's like this
is working for me
i'm buying it those little missiles
there those were uh i think we grabbed
those off one of the saturn v models the
large plastic model kit of the saturn v
from the 70s supplies tremendous amounts
of ilm greebles there's tons and tons
and tons of pieces of that that show up
all over the place so within model
making we do a lot of kit bashing and in
kit bashing you end up each model maker
ends up having certain things they like
about certain types of kits to kit bash
from
so the finest castings the finest tools
come from hasagawa and tamiya kits like
they're just the most the crispest
little details and so a lot of those and
specifically the military stuff like the
the the gun on a rail car uh with the
flak mirling has so many parts that are
in every star wars model and there is a
piece that is jokingly referred to in
the in the model making industry as the
universal greebly because it there is
one on every single star wars ship in
history we used it in the miniature of
this russian satellite and then they
built a full-size set
to our model so if you look down that
guy there is the universal greebly and
they made it like this big on the scene
and we were so excited
oh my god they built it
and the reason that is the universal
grievely is actually worth talking about
because we were talking about scale
earlier what the universal greebly is is
it's like a dome with four pips in the
corners
and because it's a dome it kicks light
from any direction from any direction at
any scale so the universal greeley works
at any scale because it always makes a
little pinpoint light kick okay wow
it's the wilhelm scream of model making
okay there you go okay there you go i
can't believe it's taking me this long
in my life to say that
adam savage a master of special effects
an absolute gem but visual and special
effects no matter how good they are they
cannot affect things in
this world in reality
but what if i told you that there was a
product that there was a today's sponsor
who could affect things in the real
world like a vfx plug-in for your hair
you might not know this but two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern bubbles by the time they're
35 well keeps us here to do something
about it they offer a wonderful
subscription service a licensed doctor
reviews your information online makes a
recommendation that's treatment just for
you and then that treatment arrives at
your door every three months keeps is
more affordable than many of the other
competitors because they offer generic
versions of already approved fda drugs
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months before you start
seeing results but that's why you need
to start today if you're experiencing
male pattern baldness prevention is the
key the easiest way to prevent hair loss
is to keep the hair that you currently
have keeps offers great online tools so
you can be in 24 7 contact with your
doctor ask them any questions you have
along the way and with their keeps
progress tracker you can keep track of
your progress along the way now if
that's not enough i'm going to give you
50 off right now okay go to keeps.com
corridor crew or click the link in the
description and that's exactly what
you'll get 50
off by going to k-e-e-p-s dot com
corridor crew
okay thanks for listening to my story
and now back to the episode
my mind is blown i'm overloaded with
awesome information and i'm excited to
do even more so adam thank you so much
for coming to visit us here at the
studio and do this with us
your knowledge on this is so insightful
and like it's it's pulling back that
curtain of of of mystery i'm so glad to
hear it i tell you after one of these
things i tend to go over the
conversation in my head i want to make
sure i got all my terms right but really
also that like i know all the people
that work on this stuff and i want to do
right by them i want to make sure i
didn't tell the story wrong or overly
you know whatever i just like i i love
talking about this my whole life is
about this conversation and if you're
not watching adam's channel tested you
should be it's amazing there's so much
so much cool stuff on there go check it
out right now well thanks again adam um
we will get you back on the couch soon
but also ideally for a different kind of
collab at some point soon we got to
figure something out 100 yeah i'm in